Alice:对这个就是这个这个
Alice: Yes, this is the room.
Alice:这个房间
Alice: This room.
其他人：兄弟你能给我来为水吗，我有点渴啊
Others: Bro, can you get me some water? I'm a bit thirsty.
Alice:你喝我的水吧
Alice: Drink my water.
Alice:这帮谁的
Alice: Whose is this?
Alice:你就直接用我的吧
Alice: Just use mine.
Alice:是的其实3层
Alice: Yes, actually there are 3 floors.
Alice:第三层不能上
Alice: You can't go to the third floor.
其他人：：麻薯然后呢
Others: Mochi, and then?
其他人：盘成包切开吗
Others: Roll it up, cut it?
Tasha: 怎么有茶味
Tasha: Why does it taste like tea?
其他人：因为泡太久茶了有味了
Others: Because it soaked too long and has a tea flavor.
其他人：哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha.
Alice:怎么了请你免费喝茶喝好好好
Alice: What's up? Enjoy your free tea.
其他人：好好好
Others: Okay, okay.
其他人：是那种老板水杯里面的茶
Others: It's like the tea in the boss's cup.
其他人：多年的茶
Others: Years-old tea.
Alice:多年的茶垢
Alice: Years-old tea stains.
Alice:怎么呢
Alice: What's up?
其他人：那是什么
Others: What's that?
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
其他人：对对角有个地方翻白
Others: Right, there's a spot in the corner turning white.
Alice:我真服了
Alice: I'm really impressed.
Tasha: 嗨
Tasha: Hi.
Alice:行了刘婷
Alice: Alright, Liu Ting.
Alice:别找了足够数我了
Alice: Stop looking, I have enough.
Alice:我要杀死这游戏哈哈哈
Alice: I'm gonna kill this game, hahaha.
Alice:给别的嘉宾留一点
Alice: Save some for the other guests.
Alice:大家还没到齐
Alice: Not everyone is here yet.
其他人：OK还有几个人
Others: Okay, how many more people?
Alice:呃我也不知道
Alice: Uh, I don't know either.
Alice:刘婷你你你上瘾了是吧
Alice: Liu Ting, are you addicted?
Alice:这个像不像
Alice: Does this look like it?
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:如果把他想象成
Alice: If you imagine it...
其他人：你们能不能正常一
Others: Can you guys act normal for once?
Alice:如果把他想象成
Alice: If you imagine it...
Alice:扭蛋抓的挺有劲哈哈哈
Alice: The gashapon is quite strong, hahaha.
其他人：哦    YOU
Others: Oh, YOU.
Alice:我有
Alice: I have one.
Alice:可以用我的充这个
Alice: You can use my charger.
Alice:这个充电宝上有那个那个啥连的线
Alice: This power bank has that cable.
其他人：你要随身带一个充电桩
Others: You always carry a charger with you?
Alice:对
Alice: Yes.
Alice:这眼睛需要充着电用哎
Alice: These glasses need to be charged.
Alice:要不你搁那充吧
Alice: Why don't you charge it there?
Alice:你看那底下那不
Alice: Look, isn't that...
Alice:哎呀这不缺的就是充电宝
Alice: There’s plenty of power banks.
Alice:你瞅见了吗
Alice: Did you see that?
其他人： 那边全都是充电
Others: Over there, it's all chargers.
Alice:这不是充电宝是啥呀
Alice: Isn't that a power bank?
Alice:充上呗
Alice: Go ahead, charge it.
Alice:研究吧哎
Alice: Study it, hey.
Alice:怎么就一个了呢
Alice: Why is there only one?
Alice:但好像是头不太对
Alice: But it seems the head is not right.
其他人：没有没有没有
Others: No, no, no.
其他人：苹果的线
Others: An Apple cable.
Alice:那你用我这个吧
Alice: Then use mine.
Alice:不是不是
Alice: No, no.
Alice:待会待会我拿我的给你充吧
Alice: Wait, I'll charge it for you later.
Alice:我那个在屋里那个线
Alice: The cable is in my room.
Alice:你不累吗
Alice: Aren't you tired?
Alice:你坐那马上骑会吧
Alice: Sit down and ride for a bit.
Tasha: 又吃了
Tasha: Ate again.
Alice:怎么了你别又瞅见了啊
Alice: What's up? Don't tell me you saw it again.
其他人：我在下面看到一个
Others: I saw one down there.
其他人：你是在这儿布置好几天是吗
Others: Have you been setting this up for days?
Alice:可以
Alice: Sure.
Tasha: 这没这个
Tasha: This doesn't have it.
Jake:怎么了哦
Jake: What's wrong? Oh.
Tasha: 恩
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake:好的谢谢了
Jake: Alright, thanks.
其他人：这几天都是在这自己做饭
Others: Have you been cooking for yourself these days?
Alice:嗯那倒不是
Alice: Well, not really.
Alice:大部分点外卖
Alice: Mostly ordering takeout.
Alice:然后有时候做火锅烧烤之类的
Alice: And sometimes making hotpot or BBQ.
Alice:就录一下那个活动
Alice: Just recording those activities.
其他人：今天结束吗嗯
Others: Is it ending today?
Alice:嗯对
Alice: Yeah.
Alice:然后明天就收尾
Alice: And then we wrap up tomorrow.
Tasha: 然后明天输
Tasha: And then we lose tomorrow.
其他人：所以明天还是不能去上班
Others: So we still can't go to work tomorrow?
Alice:yes
Alice: Yes.
Shure: where is man
Shure: Where is the guy?
其他人：我可以把最难的那个告诉你
Others: I can tell you the hardest one.
其他人：最难的那个
Others: The hardest one.
其他人：我藏在你装饰的门把手
Others: I hid it in the handle of your decoration.
其他人：哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahahahahaha!
其他人：对我就藏一个我把最难的藏起来了
Others: Yeah, I hid the hardest one.
其他人：告诉他哈哈哈哈
Others: Tell him, hahaha.
其他人：没有只有一个只有一个
Others: No, there's only one, only one.
其他人：非常的高级
Others: Very classy.
其他人：首先你看一圈那个拉
Others: First, take a look around.
其他人：后面吧OK
Others: At the back, OK.
其他人：要确认他们
Others: Make sure they're
其他人：接着就可以了
Others: Then you're good.
其他人：你确认他们开多少店我觉得
Others: Confirm how many stores they've opened, I think.
其他人：你觉得多少是一个警戒线
Others: How many do you think is the warning line?
其他人：你们的床是大通铺
Others: Your beds are all connected?
Alice:不是每人一个房间
Alice: No, everyone has their own room.
其他人：哦要不要贴这个眼睛
Others: Oh, should we stick this eye?
其他人：哦这个是在这儿贴的我以为是戴的
Others: Oh, it's to be stuck here, I thought it was to be worn.
其他人：不随身 带这么猎奇的东西
Others: No, I don't carry such a bizarre thing.
Alice:哎糖
Alice: Hey, candy.
Alice:这个这个不会有什么专门的用处吧
Alice: This, this doesn't have any special purpose, right?
Alice:这是谁的
Alice: Whose is this?
Tasha: 我的
Tasha: Mine.
Alice:这个是有什么专门的用处吗
Alice: Does this have any special purpose?
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Alice:就可以随便贴着玩是吧
Alice: So you can just stick it wherever for fun, right?
Tasha: 恩
Tasha: Yeah.
Alice:来吧一人一个
Alice: Come on, everyone gets one.
Tasha: 我的那个
Tasha: Mine is that one.
其他人：那你这五天干什么
Others: So what have you been doing these past five days?
Alice:再说
Alice: We'll see.
Alice:想到一天是一天
Alice: Just taking it one day at a time.
其他人：主要是想着买了去的票
Others: Mainly thinking about the tickets we bought.
其他人：还是买回来的票好烦
Others: And the return tickets, it's so annoying.
Alice:没关系在哪都一样
Alice: It's okay, it's the same wherever you are.
Alice:五一爆炸人多
Alice: May Day is going to be crowded.
Alice:哎要不我去你家玩吧刘婷
Alice: Hey, how about I go to your place, Liu Ting?
其他人：这个还可以
Others: That could work.
其他人：那是另外的价钱
Others: But that's a different cost.
Alice:怎么了你不应该邀请我一下吗
Alice: What's the matter, shouldn't you invite me?
Alice:你现在可以对我发出邀请
Alice: You can invite me now.
Jake:呃你换掉的在哪充电呢
Jake: Uh, where are you charging the one you replaced?
其他人：你现在可以尖叫逃跑哈哈哈
Others: Now you can scream and run away, haha.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Alice:不去你家玩了
Alice: Not going to your place anymore.
Alice:刘婷给我准备好床
Alice: Liu Ting, prepare a bed for me.
Alice:我要我要
Alice: I want, I want...
Alice:新的拖鞋床单被罩
Alice: New slippers, sheets, and duvet cover.
Alice:可以用你的床也要躺你的
Alice: I can use your bed, but I also want to lie in it.
其他人：YOU
Others: YOU.
其他人：你真是靠你这个频率
Others: You really rely on this frequency.
其他人：每周都出去逛个景点
Others: Going to a scenic spot every week.
其他人：估计北京迟早让你
Others: I bet Beijing will...
Alice:我也逛完了差不多
Alice: I've almost seen it all.
其他人：逛老棒了
Others: You’ve explored it all.
Alice:完蛋了差你家没去了
Alice: Oh no, I haven't been to your place yet.
Alice:能不能给我唱一首北京欢迎你
Alice: Can you sing me "Beijing Welcomes You"?
Alice:就是我家大门常打开
Alice: Like, "My door is always open."
其他人：（歌声）我家大门常打开
Others: (Singing) "My door is always open."
Alice:我都不知道你家门在哪开哈哈哈
Alice: I don't even know where your door opens haha.
其他人：不知道就好哈哈哈
Others: It's better that you don't know haha.
Alice:你真的不邀请我去你家玩吗
Alice: Are you really not inviting me to your house to play?
其他人：我这邀请你去我家玩不给我增添家务吗
Others: If I invite you over, won't you just add to my chores?
Alice:对呀又可以又可以
Alice: Yeah, you can say that, you can say that.
其他人：给我增加压力
Others: It'll just add stress for me.
Alice:给你可以让你多运动啊
Alice: But it can help you exercise more!
其他人：YOU不给自个儿找事儿干嘛
Others: Why are you making trouble for yourself?
Alice:精奶袋袋
Alice: Jing Nai Dai Dai.
Alice:大馋丫头哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: You greedy girl hahaha.
Alice:是不是我的呀
Alice: Is this mine?
Tasha: 我的
Tasha: It's mine.
Alice:那个看见好像没有人用哎
Alice: That one looks like no one's using it though.
Alice:这个这个
Alice: This one, this one.
其他人：那里有这样的空瓶子吗
Others: Are there any empty bottles like that?
Alice:要不你玩那个拼图吧
Alice: How about you play with that puzzle?
Alice:我看你在这挺没事干的
Alice: I see you're pretty bored here.
其他人：我考我这手机充着电呢我玩我手机吧还是
Others: Well, my phone is charging, so I'll just play on my phone instead.
Alice:OK了
Alice: Okay then.
Tasha: 等一下我已经再准备了
Tasha: Wait, I'm getting ready.
其他人：这是在做什么
Others: What is this for?
Alice:麻薯
Alice: Mochi.
Alice:刘婷你这特别像一个什么神仙下凡
Alice: Liu Ting, you look like a celestial being coming down to earth.
Alice:你这装扮
Alice: Your outfit.
Alice:你这大赤耳朵
Alice: Your big red ears.
其他人：二郎神有三只眼
Others: Erlang Shen has three eyes.
Alice:有福之相
Alice: You look blessed.
其他人：不沾项链试试
Others: Try not wearing a necklace.
其他人：哎呀你这给我粘
Others: Oh, you're sticking it on me.
其他人：头发粘上去了
Others: My hair is stuck.
Alice:那不是你自己粘的吗
Alice: Isn't that your own doing?
其他人：你粘的你
Others: You stuck it on me.
Alice:你放什么屁呢
Alice: What nonsense are you talking about?
其他人：看你干的好事
Others: Look what you've done.
Alice:那不你自己粘的吗
Alice: Isn't it your own fault?
其他人：我粘的是你耳朵上的
Others: I stuck it on your ear.
Alice:你耳朵是你自己粘的呀你忘了
Alice: You stuck it on your own ear, remember?
其他人：你忘了你不粘了吗
Others: Didn't you stick it on me?
Alice:我没给你粘
Alice: I didn't stick it on you.
Alice:你自己粘的
Alice: You did it yourself.
其他人：啊啊啊
Others: Ah ah ah
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Alice:你怎么乱污蔑人呢
Alice: Why are you falsely accusing people?
Alice:你这人
Alice: You're something else
其他人：你这社会小主吗
Others: Are you the boss of society?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
其他人：哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha
Tasha: 挤吧挤挤
Tasha: Squeeze it, squeeze it
Tasha: 一个小团子一个小团子
Tasha: One little ball at a time
Alice:挤一个爱心型的
Alice: Squeeze one into a heart shape
Tasha: 一个爱心型的
Tasha: A heart shape
Alice:哈哈哈送给刘婷哈
Alice: Hahaha, give it to Liu Ting
Tasha: 那挤不出来
Tasha: I can't squeeze it out
其他人：好油啊你
Others: You're so greasy
其他人：没人管管你吗
Others: Isn't anyone going to control you?
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Katrina: 微微那个空调遥控器有在你房间吗
Katrina: Tasha, do you have the AC remote in your room?
Tasha: 不在
Tasha: No
Katrina: 也不在我房间哎
Katrina: It's not in my room either
Katrina: 在你房间吗
Katrina: Is it in your room?
Katrina: 露西嗯
Katrina: Lucia?
Lucia: 呃应该没有
Lucia: Uh, I don't think so
其他人：嗯咱俩就在这等着骑
Others: Yeah, we'll just wait here to ride
Lucia: 我从来没有见到
Lucia: I've never seen it
Katrina: 哇你这样子玩的吗
Katrina: Wow, are you playing like this?
Alice:我能团成这个吧
Alice: Can I make it into a ball?
Tasha: 就就这样吧放哎
Tasha: Just leave it like this
Katrina: 因为我没有打火机
Katrina: Because I don't have a lighter
Katrina: 你问那个
Katrina: Ask that
Tasha: 不用你一直挤就行了
Tasha: No need, just keep squeezing it
Katrina: 谢谢谢冰烛借就行
Katrina: Thank Ice Candle, just borrow it
Alice:可是我觉得我想给他团成圆圆的
Alice: But I want to make it round
Tasha: 可是我觉得我想给他团上去
Tasha: But I want to put it up there
Katrina: 他那个打火机好像棉签有点用完了
Katrina: His lighter's cotton swab seems to be used up
Tasha: 不不不不太慢了啊
Tasha: No no no, it's too slow
Katrina: 然后就不太好找哦
Katrina: So it's hard to find
Tasha: 你往粉的地方放
Tasha: Put it in the powder area
Tasha: 不然我拿不下来
Tasha: Otherwise, I can't take it down
Katrina: 完了没空调遥控器
Katrina: No AC remote
Tasha: 拿不下来了已经
Tasha: It's already stuck
Katrina: 没有空调遥控器
Katrina: There's no AC remote.
Lucia: 那个空调遥控器
Lucia: That AC remote.
其他人：看看你干的好事儿
Others: Look what you've done.
Lucia: 我好像就没怎么见过
Lucia: I don't think I've ever seen it.
其他人：这是叫什么来着
Others: What's this called again?
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Hey
Katrina: 这有一个空调遥控器应该都能通用吧
Katrina: One AC remote should work for all, right?
其他人：麻薯就是那个粉
Others: The mochi powder.
Alice:放
Alice: Put it.
Alice:黄豆粉
Alice: Soybean powder.
Katrina: 这这个
Katrina: This one.
Tasha: 太小了再挤大一点
Tasha: It's too small, squeeze it a bit bigger.
Alice:好热呀你热不热
Alice: It's so hot, aren't you hot?
Tasha: 还好就这么大就行
Tasha: It's fine, this size is good.
其他人：哎呦我跟你那个
Others: Oh my, with that...
其他人：那个卖菠萝蛋糕的那个商家说了
Others: I talked to the pineapple cake seller.
其他人：改那个地址
Others: About changing the address.
其他人：但好像平台上面没有显示
Others: But it doesn't seem to show on the platform.
Alice:那怎么办呢
Alice: So what do we do?
其他人：不出意外的话
Others: Unless there's an accident,
Alice:你为什么不给我勾一个
Alice: Why don't you mark it for me?
Alice:你要买现成的
Alice: You should buy a ready-made one.
其他人：那就八辈子能收着啊
Others: That will take forever to receive.
其他人：我估计我做出来的时候
Others: By the time I make it,
Tasha: 其他人：
Tasha: Others:
其他人：你别整啊
Others: Don't bother.
Alice:行在你
Alice: Fine, at your
Alice:我在你心里就只这一点点位置
Alice: To you, I only take up this tiny bit of space in your heart.
其他人：我不会
Others: I won't.
Alice:你不会为我学吗
Alice: You won't learn it for me?
其他人：天呐你急死我得了
Others: Oh my god, you're driving me crazy.
Lucia: 我试图粘一个水母出来
Lucia: I tried to stick a jellyfish.
其他人：我连拼图都不愿意拼的人
Others: I don't even like doing puzzles.
其他人：你觉得我会学这个吗
Others: Do you think I would learn this?
Lucia: 本来是要做一个水母灯的
Lucia: I was going to make a jellyfish lamp.
Tasha: 哈哈好我懂了
Tasha: Haha, I get it.
Alice:好我懂了
Alice: Okay, I get it.
Lucia: 但是没有买灯珠
Lucia: But I didn't buy the LED beads.
Alice:我就在你心里那么一点点的位置
Alice: So I only take up this tiny bit of space in your heart.
其他人：哦哈哈哈
Others: Oh, hahaha
Alice:你用它测测你心里的温度吧我觉得
Alice: Why don't you measure the temperature of your heart with this? I think...
其他人：零下零下18度
Others: Minus 18 degrees.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Alice:零下200度
Alice: Minus 200 degrees.
其他人：应该是差什么
Others: Maybe something's missing.
其他人：应该差蛋液什么还是什么
Others: Maybe it needs egg yolk or something.
Tasha: 放可可的吧
Tasha: Add cocoa, right?
Tasha: 你的药
Tasha: Your medicine.
Tasha: 我看到
Tasha: I saw it.
Alice:6啊你这眼睛是咋长的呀
Alice: Wow, your eyes are sharp!
其他人：我眼睛都是尺
Others: My eyes are like rulers.
其他人：两个口味
Others: Two flavors.
Alice:是的
Alice: Yes.
其他人：先人都齐了吗
Others: Is everyone here?
Alice:让你吃了吗
Alice: Did I allow you to eat?
Tasha: 不道 呀
Tasha: I don't know.
其他人：哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha.
Alice:大馋丫头
Alice: You greedy girl.
其他人：你都把我招到这来了你还怕我吃
Others: You invited me here, and you're afraid I'll eat?
Lucia: 呃我有一个朋友可能会来
Lucia: Uh, I might have a friend coming over.
Alice:给你个原味的
Alice: Here's an original flavor for you.
Alice:给
Alice: Here.
Lucia: 对然后
Lucia: Yeah, and then...
其他人：恩恩
Others: Mm-hmm.
Alice:快点
Alice: Hurry up.
其他人：别搞哈哈
Others: Don't mess around, haha.
Alice:这只是味有点淡而已
Alice: This one just has a lighter taste.
Jake:我们现在
Jake: We're now...
Jake:我们现在算齐了
Jake: We're all here now.
Lucia: 对他有可能来
Lucia: Yeah, he might come.
Jake:哦这么哈哈哈好嘞
Jake: Oh, really? Haha, okay.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Jake:好的没关系
Jake: Alright, no problem.
Jake:那我们就
Jake: Then we...
Lucia: 因为理论上说就是就是那个男生
Lucia: Because theoretically, that guy...
Lucia: 他今天应该会
Lucia: He should...
Lucia: 就是有时间应该会过来
Lucia: He should come today.
Lucia: 不过他现在没跟我说他到哪了
Lucia: But he hasn't told me where he is yet.
Jake:好没关系
Jake: Okay, no problem.
Lucia: 那个妹子的话
Lucia: That girl...
Lucia: 他因为太远了就不太方便
Lucia: It's quite inconvenient because it's too far.
Lucia: 如果他来的话就要来两个小时左右
Lucia: If he comes, it would take about two hours.
Lucia: 然后回去还得回两个小时
Lucia: And going back would take another two hours.
Lucia: 就不是很方便
Lucia: So it's not very convenient.
其他人： 一会你们把这些凳子要不都搬上去
Others: Why don't you move these chairs upstairs in a bit?
Jake:你你来搬吧
Jake: You, you move them.
其他人：他们不是在坐着吗
Others: Aren't they sitting on them?
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
其他人：哦站起来
Others: Oh, stand up.
Jake:不是我们我们开开个场
Jake: No, no, let's just start first.
Jake:然后
Jake: Then...
Tasha: 然后
Tasha: Then...
Jake:我想一想我想一想这边可能
Jake: Let me think, let me think, maybe here...
Lucia: 关一下
Lucia: Close it.
Jake:就我们得都上去
Jake: We should all go upstairs.
Jake:那这个我们能上去搞吗
Jake: Can we handle this upstairs?
Alice:这个快这个快弄好
Alice: This will be done quickly.
其他人：要不搞完再上去
Others: Maybe finish this first and then go up.
Jake:要不这一头
Jake: How about this end?
Jake:这这这一波
Jake: This, this, this batch.
Jake:这波搞完我上去
Jake: Once we finish this batch, I'll go up.
Jake:好行上去就介绍一下然后开场
Jake: Okay, go up and do a little introduction, then start.
Jake:呃到处每个房间走一走
Jake: Uh, walk around each room.
Tasha: 不可以
Tasha: No, you can't.
Jake:装饰完了吗
Jake: Is it fully decorated?
其他人：是没熟
Others: It's not ready.
Jake:那
Jake: Then...
其他人：熟了吗这个
Others: Is this ready?
Jake:好那就可以看是吧
Jake: Okay, then it can be viewed, right?
Tasha: 熟了还没有配料呢
Tasha: It's ready but there are no seasonings.
Jake:但那什么时候能出完全比完全平
Jake: When will it be completely finished and level?
其他人：没事我尝一个
Others: No worries, I'll taste one.
Tasha: 不行没有配料不好吃
Tasha: No, without seasonings, it doesn't taste good.
Jake:完全的屋子
Jake: The whole house.
其他人：我尝一个原味
Others: I'll taste one original flavor.
Jake:完整状态
Jake: In its complete state.
Lucia: 呃对但是上去之前
Lucia: Uh, yes, but before going up...
Tasha: 这个不是原味
Tasha: This is not the original flavor.
Jake:今晚的完整状态
Jake: Tonight in its complete state.
Tasha: 还有尝不出来
Tasha: You can't taste it.
Lucia: 我会需要把那个东西再粘一下
Lucia: I need to stick that thing back on.
Alice:这是原味
Alice: This is the original flavor.
Jake:哦OK
Jake: Oh, OK.
Lucia: 不然他就会掉
Lucia: Otherwise, it'll fall off.
Lucia: 你可以先寻别的房间
Lucia: You can check other rooms first.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 哈哈可以
Lucia: Haha, sure.
Lucia: 对对对你们去别的房间的时候
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, when you guys go to other rooms.
Alice:麻薯
Alice: Mochi.
Lucia: 我就溜进去整理我的
Lucia: I'll sneak in and tidy up mine.
Alice:确实驴打滚的亲戚
Alice: It's like a relative of the "rolling donkey."
其他人：恩
Others: Yeah.
Alice:还能黄豆吗
Alice: Can we still use soybeans?
Tasha: 应该还够
Tasha: Should be enough.
Alice:有点少反正
Alice: It's a bit less, though.
Alice:不过差不多匀一点
Alice: But we can just spread it out a bit.
Tasha: 行那就挪一挪
Tasha: Alright, let's just move it around.
Lucia: 但这个有点小
Lucia: But this is a bit small.
Jake:没关系没关系
Jake: It's fine, it's fine.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Alice:这是熟的蒸过的
Alice: This is cooked, it's been steamed.
Alice:怎么我还能毒死你吗
Alice: What, you think I'd poison you?
Alice:我毒死你也不会在这
Alice: If I wanted to poison you, I wouldn't do it here.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
其他人：哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahahaha.
其他人：这那么多摄像头你笑什么
Others: With so many cameras around, why are you laughing?
其他人：好现在找9个凳子
Others: Alright, now let's find 9 chairs.
其他人：现在是6个
Others: We have 6 now.
其他人：哈哈
Others: Haha.
Jake:行这小这小马可以反正就
Jake: Alright, this small horse is fine.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mhm.
其他人：那我来骑马吧
Others: Then I'll ride the horse.
Jake:那就算了
Jake: Never mind then.
Jake:太重了是吧
Jake: Too heavy, right?
Jake:牛批哎呀
Jake: Awesome, oh man.
Shure: 他是EGO house
Shure: He's EGO house.
Shure: 你是IGO Knight
Shure: You're IGO Knight.
其他人：骑士
Others: Knight.
其他人：试图在拯救出一个来
Others: Trying to save one.
Tasha: 好了没事儿不用了不用了
Tasha: Alright, it's fine, no need anymore.
Alice:你要吃哪个味刘婷
Alice: Which flavor do you want, Liu Ting?
Alice:我都吃不行吗
Alice: Can I have them all?
Alice:不我要给你弄一个小的
Alice: No, I'll get you a small one.
Shure: 你干什么
Shure: What are you doing?
Shure: 不是你你是骑士
Shure: No, you're the knight.
Shure: 戴耳钉会怎么样吗
Shure: What happens if you wear earrings?
Alice:不爱吃可可
Alice: I don't like cocoa.
其他人：我戴的是耳钉吗
Others: Am I wearing earrings?
其他人：别他妈自我代入
Others: Don't put yourself in my shoes.
Shure: 你戴的是摇滚是吗哈哈
Shure: So you're rocking it, huh? Haha.
Alice:爱心
Alice: Love.
其他人：哎哈哈哈
Others: Oh, hahaha.
Alice:恶心啊快这样
Alice: Disgusting, like this.
Alice:现在不会真能吃了吧
Alice: You really can eat it now, right?
Alice:真的这是熟的公主
Alice: Seriously, this is cooked, princess.
Lucia: 之前苏出来这个造型
Lucia: This look came out earlier.
Shure: 怎么太多天看不着
Shure: How come I haven't seen it for so many days?
Lucia: 他就会往外往外撇
Lucia: He just keeps leaning out.
Shure: 没乐子看了是吗
Shure: No fun watching it, right?
Lucia: 没事凑合用一下
Lucia: It's okay, make do with it.
Shure: 把杜老喊来干嘛
Shure: Why call Du over?
Tasha: 不用m
Tasha: No need, m.
Lucia: 啊我小伙伴说他到花庄地铁站了
Lucia: Ah, my friend said he arrived at Huazhuang subway station.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:公主请吃
Alice: Princess, please eat.
Lucia: 时光旅人5号
Lucia: Time Traveler No. 5.
Alice:这是耻辱
Alice: This is a disgrace.
Lucia: 院时光旅人5号院
Lucia: Courtyard Time Traveler No. 5 Courtyard.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 轩哈
Katrina: Xuan, haha.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Lucia: 稍等一下
Lucia: Hold on a second.
Lucia: 网又不太好了
Lucia: The internet is acting up again.
Shure: 你非得要当一把大爷是吗
Shure: You insist on being the boss, huh?
Tasha: 那瓶矿泉水拿 给我一下
Tasha: Hand me that bottle of mineral water.
Shure: 什么东西
Shure: What is it?
Shure: 嫂子开门
Shure: Sis, open the door.
Shure: 我是我哥是吧
Shure: I'm your brother, right?
Tasha: 好了刚好
Tasha: Okay, that's just right.
Shure: 我们给他加油
Shure: Let's cheer him on.
Lucia: 转不出来了
Lucia: It won't turn anymore.
Lucia: 我的手机
Lucia: My phone.
其他人：我已经吸不出来水了
Alice:是不是水太少了
Alice: Is there not enough water?
Lucia: 看起来还有半瓶
Lucia: Looks like there's half a bottle left.
Alice:看起来还有很多
Alice: Seems like there's still a lot.
Alice:你点他不管用哦
Alice: Pressing it doesn't work, you know.
Alice:那个啥他没插电吗不是
Alice: Is it not plugged in or something?
Shure: 到你
Shure: Your turn.
Tasha: 没插电
Tasha: It's not plugged in.
Alice:你看那个那个那个那个
Alice: Look at that, that, that...
其他人：哦她现在在用是吗
Others: Oh, is she using it now?
Alice:呃哪个不用啊
Alice: Uh, which one is not in use?
Tasha: 微波炉不用了拔掉吧
Tasha: The microwave isn't in use, unplug it.
Alice:这个好像不用
Alice: This one seems unused.
Alice:这个你别拔错了
Alice: Don't unplug the wrong one.
Lucia: 对有一点点
Lucia: Yeah, just a little bit.
Alice:这个好像在
Alice: This one seems active.
Lucia: 没事做饭还是很容易被烫到的
Lucia: It's okay, cooking can easily get you burned.
Alice:正在通知你
Alice: It's notifying you.
Alice:要不你去其他地方把它挪走
Alice: Why don't you move it somewhere else?
Alice:二楼是不是还有水
Alice: Is there water on the second floor?
Tasha: 二楼那个是正常的
Tasha: The one on the second floor is working fine.
Alice:二楼也有
Alice: There's water on the second floor too.
Lucia: 哈哈哈都可以
Lucia: Hahaha, anything works.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 等一下我擦擦手然后给他回一下
Lucia: Wait a second, let me wipe my hands and then I'll reply.
Katrina: 你说所有吗
Katrina: You mean all of them?
Katrina: 不止不止
Katrina: Not all, not all.
Katrina: 我们都有
Katrina: We all have them.
Katrina: 10个人加6个嘉宾吧
Katrina: 10 people plus 6 guests.
其他人：加6个加
Others: Plus 6, plus...
其他人：呃是放哪里啊
Others: Uh, where should we put it?
Katrina: 呃我的打孔器呢
Katrina: Uh, where's my hole punch?
Tasha: 啊不够
Tasha: Ah, not enough.
Katrina: 又找不到
Katrina: Can't find it again.
Shure: 在外面呢
Shure: It's outside.
Shure: 你打红心
Shure: You hit the bullseye.
Katrina: 刚外面没看见呀
Katrina: Didn't see it outside just now.
Shure: 咱早上不在外面呢看着呢
Shure: We were watching outside this morning.
Katrina: 打孔器哈哈哈
Katrina: The hole punch, hahaha.
Alice:再拿一个吧
Alice: Take another one.
Tasha: 啊停搞错了
Tasha: Ah, stop, it's wrong.
其他人：不要不干什么
Others: Don't do nothing.
其他人：你怎么老一脸嫌弃看我
Others: Why do you always look at me with disdain?
Alice:干什么有肉
Alice: What are you doing with the meat?
Alice:有江浦还江浦了
Alice: There's Jiangpu, and more Jiangpu.
Alice:刘婷你愿意出多少钱买我的狗
Alice: Liu Ting, how much would you pay for my dog?
爱丽其他人：什么你让我花钱
Others: What, you want me to spend money?
Alice:哈哈我的狗不值钱吗
Alice: Haha, is my dog worthless?
Alice:在外边呢
Alice: It's outside.
Tasha: 让一下
Tasha: Move aside.
Alice:你能把他迎接回来吗
Alice: Can you welcome him back?
Alice:待会再迎接吧
Alice: Let's welcome him back later.
Alice:你愿意出多少买它
Alice: How much are you willing to pay for it?
其他人：哈哈
Others: Haha.
其他人：你的心里价位是多少
Others: What's your ideal price?
Alice:200
Alice: 200.
其他人：真荒谬
Others: That's ridiculous.
其他人：用不用打120
Others: Do we need to call 120?
Alice:你的你的房间装饰好了吗
Alice: Is your room decorated yet?
Lucia: 好了就就就这样吧
Lucia: Yes, it's done, just like that.
Lucia: 管他呢反正好了就
Lucia: Whatever, it's done.
Lucia: 哈哈你见过我的完整版吗
Lucia: Haha, have you seen my complete version?
Lucia: 我可以看一下吗
Lucia: Can I have a look?
Lucia: 可以谢谢
Lucia: Okay, thanks.
Lucia: 我那个在大家去看之前
Lucia: Before everyone goes to see it,
Lucia: 我还再去粘一下
Lucia: I'll stick it again.
Lucia: 因为美纹纸特别容易掉
Lucia: Because the masking tape falls off easily.
Lucia: 我掉了还没粘上呢
Lucia: It fell off and I haven't stuck it back yet.
Alice:我哦我掉了还没粘上呢
Alice: Oh, mine fell off and I haven't stuck it back yet.
Lucia: 哦没事
Lucia: Oh, it's okay.
Alice:好的我去我去补救一下
Alice: Okay, I'll go fix it.
Lucia: 那你去修整一下
Lucia: Then you go fix it.
Lucia: 我跟你一起去修整一下
Lucia: I'll go fix it with you.
Tasha: 这怎么办
Tasha: What should we do?
Alice:没关系
Alice: It's okay.
Lucia: 哇你的房间好香呀哎
Lucia: Wow, your room smells so good.
Lucia: 可惜还没有过来
Lucia: It's a pity it hasn't come over yet.
Alice:拿个什么
Alice: What should I take?
Alice:那个水杯给我吧
Alice: Give me that cup.
Alice:这是巧克力豆
Alice: These are chocolate beans.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Alice:比我命还硬
Alice: Harder than my life.
Tasha: 算了
Tasha: Forget it.
Alice:哦有一点碎的下面有
Alice: Oh, there's a bit crushed underneath.
其他人：干啥
Others: What's up?
Alice:刘婷你吃巧克力吗
Alice: Liu Ting, do you eat chocolate?
其他人：啊不
Others: Ah, no.
Tasha: 姐
Tasha: Sis.
Tasha: 没事
Tasha: It's okay.
其他人：好吃吗
Others: Is it tasty?
Alice:给
Alice: Here.
其他人：啊不不不不不不
Others: Ah no no no no no.
Alice:公主请吃
Alice: Princess, please eat.
其他人：别别别
Others: No, no, no.
Tasha: 然后这个就可以拿上去了
Tasha: And then this can be taken up.
Tasha: 但是也可以最后在拿就是一起拿
Tasha: But you can also take it up together at the end.
Tasha: 蛋塔还没烤还要半个小时就全部做完了
Tasha: The egg tarts aren't baked yet, need another half an hour and everything will be done.
其他人：这个不需要冰了
Others: This doesn't need to be chilled.
Tasha: 这个冰一下的话会变硬
Tasha: If you chill this, it will get hard.
Tasha: 趁热吃
Tasha: Eat it while it's hot.
Tasha: 不拉丝了
Tasha: No more cheese pull.
Tasha: 然后提拉米苏拿出来
Tasha: And then take out the tiramisu.
其他人：：哇
Others: Wow.
Tasha: 衣服拿一下吧
Tasha: Take the clothes.
Tasha: 这能都洗一下吗
Tasha: Can you wash all these?
Alice:不要偷吃
Alice: Don't steal food.
Alice:刘婷我指名点姓的提醒你
Alice: Liu Ting, I'm calling you out specifically.
其他人：只能点点污蔑我
Others: Only to slander me a bit.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
其他人：你是不被 鬼上身了哈
Others: Are you possessed by a ghost?
Alice:不是本人刚刚好像有什么东西上我身了
Alice: No, just now it felt like something took over me.
Katrina: 你帮我把其他都打了吧
Katrina: Can you help me beat the rest?
Alice:哈哈哈退退
Alice: Hahaha, retreat, retreat.
Tasha: 开一下开啊
Tasha: Open it, open it.
Tasha: 没事没事别动
Tasha: It's okay, it's okay, don't move.
Tasha: 好了吗筛子要用
Tasha: Is it ready? Need the sieve.
Alice:你跟我在一块那么久你你不了解我
Alice: You've been with me for so long, don't you know me?
其他人：不是我说他的那个声音是传出来的
Others: No, I mean his voice is coming out.
Alice:手机壳妈呀
Alice: Phone case, oh my god.
其他人：不是我的吧啊我的
Jake:这样这样这样
Alice:你有
其他人：这怎么好湿呢
Tasha: 嗯湿的不行
Alice:爱情好像流沙
Tasha: 没事
Tasha: 好了没事
Alice:要不你去把我那挂纸给贴上
Tasha: 啊先不着急处那个你能拿
Alice:咱俩这关
Alice:你给我提钱
Alice:你刚才还说我要买你的狗
Alice:哈哈哈我的狗不值二百吗
其他人：我的劳动不值二百吗
Alice:我还我就跟你说人民币
Alice:我还没说刀呢
Alice:我还没给你算别的币种呢
Alice:我给你算人民币你还嫌我黑
其他人：  怎么能够假装不小心摘了蛋糕
Others: How can you pretend you accidentally took the cake?
Jake:我来切
Jake: I'll cut it.
Jake:哈哈不理我
Jake: Haha, ignoring me.
Jake:算了算了算
Jake: Forget it, forget it.
Alice:真都假都你知道怎么挂吗
Alice: Whether it's real or fake, do you even know how to hang it?
Alice:那你就这么自信的走过去
Alice: You're just confidently walking over.
Alice:你再给我装饰
Alice: Now decorate it for me.
Alice:破坏了美景破坏了
Alice: Ruined the scenery, ruined it.
Jake:嗯咱还是不回了哈哈
Jake: Hmm, let's not go back, haha.
Jake:哈喽哈喽
Jake: Hello, hello.
Alice:你用那个纸
Alice: Use that paper.
Alice:是
Alice: Yes.
Jake:哎你好
Jake: Hey, hi.
Alice:用这个
Alice: Use this.
Alice:你把它打开一下呗
Alice: Open it up for me, will you?
其他人：哈哈好烦啊谁说我没 什么东西
Others: Haha, so annoying. Who said I didn't have... What is this?
Shure: 热
Shure: Hot.
Tasha: 行呵
Tasha: Alright, okay.
Tasha: 还差一道
Tasha: One more to go.
Tasha: 好呵
Tasha: Okay, alright.
Tasha: 然后我在想就这样子拿上去
Tasha: Then I was thinking of just taking it up like this.
Jake:你们这么压是有用的吗
Jake: Is it useful to press it like this?
Tasha: 还是说放在盘里
Tasha: Or should we put it on a plate?
Tasha: 再
Tasha: Then...
Tasha: 也可以把这个带上去然后等会再分它
Tasha: We could also take this up and then divide it later.
Tasha: 行然后装饰
Tasha: Okay, and then decorate it.
Tasha: 薄荷叶呢卖的
Tasha: Where are the mint leaves sold?
Tasha: 啊受不了了
Tasha: Ah, I can't stand it.
Tasha: 好大薄荷叶受不了
Tasha: Such big mint leaves, I can't stand it.
Tasha: 嘿嘿
Tasha: Hehe.
其他人：没事没事正好盖上
Others: It's okay, it's okay, it covers it perfectly.
Tasha: 这片落了
Tasha: This piece fell.
其他人：蛋给我
Others: Give me the egg.
Tasha: 搞个哎哟天哪
Tasha: Oh my gosh.
Alice:薄荷香
Alice: Minty fragrance.
Tasha: 哎哟天那
Tasha: Oh my gosh.
Alice:我们不是买了那个半半
Alice: Didn't we buy that half-half thing?
Tasha: 天呐好不一致呀好丑呀
Tasha: Oh my gosh, so inconsistent and so ugly.
其他人： 没关系好吃就行
Others: It's okay, as long as it tastes good.
Tasha: 不要
Tasha: No.
Tasha: 哎呀
Tasha: Oh no.
Lucia: 我已经生了
Lucia: I already gave birth.
Tasha: 恩
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 豆呢刚才的豆呢
Tasha: Where are the beans from earlier?
其他人：洗了吗洗了吗
Others: Did you wash them?
Alice:这个洗过也可以吃
Alice: These have been washed and can be eaten.
Tasha: 豆
Tasha: Beans.
Alice:巧克力豆吗
Alice: Chocolate beans?
其他人：那那那那
Others: Those, those, those.
其他人：把这个大的给
Others: Give the big one.
Tasha: 呜没关系这种事儿在我们这儿经常发生
Tasha: Ooh, it's okay, this kind of thing happens often here.
Alice:你想给我们捐点吗
Alice: Do you want to donate some to us?
其他人：什么我是想存吗我想黑点
Others: What? I want to save it, I want to blacken it.
Alice:你来报销
Alice: You reimburse it.
Alice:这话是可以说的吗
Alice: Can you say this?
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Huh?
Alice:这话你当我面说就行了别当老板面说
Alice: You can say this to me, but not in front of the boss.
Alice:啥
Alice: What?
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Huh?
Alice:你这快贴脸上了
Alice: You're almost putting it on your face.
Alice:睫毛你知道你真是掀
Alice: Eyelashes, you know, you're really lifting them up.
Tasha: 比较有要求的女生
Tasha: She's a girl with high standards.
Alice:比较有要求的一个小女孩那必须
Alice: A girl with high standards, that's for sure.
其他人：进来点
Others: Come in a bit.
Alice:像像
Alice: Like, like.
Alice:你别再发出那种魔性的声音了好吗
Alice: Can you please stop making that weird noise?
其他人：哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha.
Alice:我跟你说啊
Alice: I'm telling you.
Alice:你万一发生了像那天的事
Alice: If something like that happens again...
Alice:我跟你说你今年你就得内向了
Alice: I'm telling you, you'll become introverted this year.
Alice:你知道吗
Alice: You know?
Tasha: 好够了够了
Tasha: Alright, enough, enough.
其他人：哈哈哈不会吧哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha, no way, hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:有哈哈哈
Alice: Yeah, hahaha.
其他人：有哈哈哈
Others: Yeah, hahaha.
Alice:会重蹈覆辙的我跟你说
Alice: I'm telling you, you'll repeat the same mistakes.
Alice:我只能这么告诉你
Alice: That's all I can say.
其他人：哈哈哈好哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha, alright, hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈好
Alice: Hahaha, alright.
Alice:哈哈哈怎么不唱了
Alice: Hahaha, why'd you stop singing?
Alice:怎么不唱了
Alice: Why'd you stop singing?
Alice:可心酸哈
Alice: It's really sad, huh?
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Tasha: OK这个也做完了下一个
Tasha: Okay, this one's done too. Next.
Tasha: 受不了了
Tasha: Can't take it anymore.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Tasha: 擦一下
Tasha: Wipe it off.
其他人：你要是不跟我说还好现在我完全警惕
Others: If you hadn't told me, I wouldn't have noticed. Now I'm completely alert.
Alice:你现在怎么变内向了
Alice: Why are you so introverted now?
Alice:刘婷你不是挺爱说话的吗
Alice: Liu Ting, you used to be so talkative.
其他人：你看123还有蛋吗
Others: Look, 1, 2, 3, are there any eggs left?
Jake:这个扭着让大伙一起挤是吧
Jake: This twisting thing, everyone needs to squeeze together, right?
Jake:就是这个奶油
Jake: It's this cream.
Jake:奶油大伙可以自己挤
Jake: Everyone can squeeze the cream themselves.
Tasha: 什么奶油
Tasha: What cream?
Jake:这个上面会有奶油
Jake: There will be cream on top.
Tasha: 还没挤还没打因为要等蛋塔的一起打
Tasha: Haven't squeezed it yet, haven't whipped it yet, because we need to do it with the egg tarts.
Jake:还没打
Jake: Haven't whipped it yet.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Alice:怎么内向了
Alice: Why so introverted?
Alice:不唱了我记得你唱歌挺好听的呀
Alice: Not singing anymore? I remember you sing pretty well.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Tasha: 二百
Tasha: Two hundred
Alice:没事那个人好像不
Alice: It's okay, that person seems like...
Alice:在他在二楼
Alice: He's on the second floor.
其他人：后来 方式那个
Other: Later, the way that...
其他人：恩恩
Other: Mm-hmm
其他人：之前
Other: Before
其他人：之前在PDMTV
Other: Before on PDMTV
Alice:你可以吃瓜子
Alice: You can eat sunflower seeds
其他人：我不想吃
Other: I don't want to eat
Alice:你吃瓜子吗
Alice: Do you want some sunflower seeds?
Alice:咱们这个活动大概是持续到
Alice: Our event will last for about...
Alice:三天三夜哈哈哈
Alice: Three days and three nights, hahaha
Alice:咋晚上有约
Alice: Do you have plans tonight?
Alice:约谁了跟我玩还还搞时间规划
Alice: Who did you make plans with? Playing with me and still planning your time?
Alice:跟谁约
Alice: Who are you meeting?
Alice:嗯晚上78点
Alice: Hmm, around 7 or 8 PM
Alice:嗯差不多
Alice: Hmm, about right
Alice:朋友再见
Alice: Goodbye, friend
Jake:要帮忙吗
Jake: Need help?
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No
Jake:我靠这怎么这个样子
Jake: What the heck, why is it like this?
Tasha: 能铺层油纸吗
Tasha: Can we put a layer of parchment paper?
Alice:婷
Alice: Ting
Tasha: 甜这两个字不一样
Tasha: Sweet, these two words are different.
Alice:铺油纸
Alice: Put parchment paper
Tasha: 蜜油纸啊油纸
Tasha: Honey parchment paper, parchment paper
其他人：哦哦油约
Other: Oh, oh, oil appointment
其他人：我以为你说有纸呢
Other: I thought you said you had paper.
Alice:我说你低智
Alice: I said you're low IQ
Alice:有火彩
Alice: There's fireworks
其他人：要不要郑重介绍一下这
Other: Should we give a formal introduction of this?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
其他人：之前他画的那个设计图的时候我就看到了
Other: When he was drawing the design sketch before, I saw it.
其他人：不是姐们
Other: Not your sister
Alice:咋了
Alice: What happened?
其他人：还设计呢啊
Other: Still designing, huh?
Alice:这些我设计的呀
Alice: These are designed by me.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Alice:跟姐妹待这长时间都不知道什么意思
Alice: I've been with the girls for so long and still don't know what this means.
Alice:刘婷外面有狗了
Alice: Liu Ting has a dog outside.
其他人： 啊你好像没跟我说设计事儿
Others: Ah, you didn't tell me about the design thing.
Katrina: 不过就是这个东西的
Katrina: But it's just this thing...
Alice:哄不好了刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting can't be coaxed.
其他人：这样自己自己手动
Others: Just do it manually yourself.
Alice:刀不知道剪刀在哪
Alice: I don't know where the scissors are.
其他人：赶紧把手弄死吧
Others: Hurry up and finish it.
Alice:虽然有这个
Alice: Even though there's this...
Alice:但我没看见
Alice: But I didn't see it.
Alice:给你表演一个丝滑丝
Alice: Let me show you a smooth cut.
Alice:这个好吗
Alice: Is this okay?
Alice:如果不丝滑就是愿你看了
Alice: If it's not smooth, it's because you're watching.
Tasha: 几点开始啊
Tasha: When does it start?
其他人：哇
Others: Wow
Alice:你影响了观测
Alice: You're affecting the observation.
Jake:LUCIA他有人准备来
Jake: Lucia, someone is preparing to come.
Tasha: 哦哦
Tasha: Oh, oh.
Tasha: 一层右边的不能见人
Tasha: The right side of the first floor can't be seen by people.
Jake:一层
Jake: First floor.
Jake:一层要收拾
Jake: The first floor needs to be tidied up.
Jake:就一下就
Jake: Just for a bit.
Jake:露西亚有一个同学
Jake: Lucia has a classmate.
Alice:啊撕太长了
Alice: Ah, it's tearing too long.
Alice:真都假都
Alice: Real or fake?
Alice:不行我得给他剪一点上剪刀
Alice: No, I have to cut it a bit with scissors.
其他人：你打吧这剪刀比贴纸还难找
Others: Go ahead, the scissors are harder to find than the stickers.
Alice:我也这么觉得
Alice: I think so too.
Alice:我们这可缺剪刀了
Alice: We're really short on scissors here.
Alice:算了这样结吧
Alice: Forget it, let's tie it like this.
Shure: 我操
Shure: Damn.
其他人：你们之前是不是选的这种贴纸 然后这种贴约太丑所以换成这个了
Others: Did you choose these stickers before? And then they were too ugly, so you changed to these?
Alice:你慎言我跟你说那人家设计的那啥
Alice: Be careful with your words, I'm telling you, someone designed that.
其他人：啊
Others: Ah
Alice:你怎么老干那种事啊
Alice: Why do you always do that?
其他人： 哈哈
Others: Haha
其他人：你说这个是设计的
Others: You said this was designed.
其他人：这个是设计的吗
Others: Was this designed?
Tasha: 其他人：
Tasha: Others:
其他人：还蛮不错的
Others: It's pretty good.
其他人：就是相对于就是我们买到的这个
Others: Compared to what we bought...
其他人：商用的这个贴
Others: The commercial one...
其他人：我看你啊有点多了一种原点
Others: I see you, there's a bit of originality.
Alice:一点记性不长
Alice: A bit forgetful.
其他人：记性不良
Others: Forgetful.
其他人：原创的我
Others: Original me.
Alice:刘婷你说今天晚上我真的有有法
Alice: Liu Ting, you said tonight I really have...
Tasha: 我真的有有关多了一种原创的病
Tasha: I really have this originality illness.
Alice:又有的聊了咱俩
Alice: We've got something to talk about again.
其他人： 我说一句
Others: Let me say something.
其他人：这设计设计的是什么
Others: What's this design?
其他人：树枝你看出来
Others: Branches, can you see?
其他人：蜘蛛啊鸟
Others: Spider, bird.
其他人：你也是哈哈哈
Others: You too, haha.
其他人：看出来我以为他是那种
Others: I thought it was like...
其他人：就是冬天那种光秃秃的树干啊
Others: Bare branches in winter.
Lucia: 哈喽哈喽
Lucia: Hello, hello.
其他人：有树枝哈哈哈
Others: There are branches, haha.
Alice:你先上去吧
Alice: You go up first.
Alice:刘婷带着我上楼找个地坐那
Alice: Liu Ting, take me upstairs to find a place to sit.
其他人：啊干嘛 去啊
Others: What's up? Go.
Tasha: 上楼找个地儿坐着
Tasha: Go upstairs and find a place to sit.
Katrina: 不用带啥
Katrina: 什么都不用带
Katrina: Don't need to bring anything.
Katrina: 脑子都不用带
Katrina: Not even your brain.
Alice:之前搁那没地
Alice: There was no place before.
Tasha: 太大了
Tasha: Too big.
Alice:结过边还很大吗
Alice: Even after trimming, is it still big?
Tasha: 嗯我不想
Tasha: Hmm, I don't want to.
Tasha: 就是边
Tasha: Just trimming...
Alice:有剪刀没啊
Alice: Do we have scissors?
其他人：剪刀在外面
Others: Scissors are outside.
Alice:直接剪吧
Alice: Just cut it.
Alice:那个太不好用了
Alice: That one is too hard to use.
Shure: 饿了吧
Shure: Hungry?
Shure: 这个在哪 里烧
Shure: Where do we cook this?
其他人：这里
Others: Here.
Shure: 确实他会腱鞘炎的
Shure: He might really get tenosynovitis.
Shure: 我那段玩也是
Shure: I used to play that too.
Katrina: 这是他们的货币拿着不
Katrina: Is this their currency? Should I take it?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
其他人：拿着
Others: Take it.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Alice:刘婷顾头不顾腚
Alice: Liu Ting only cares about the head, not the tail.
Tasha: 盆盆
Tasha: The bowl.
Alice:刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting.
Tasha: 曲姐那个盆在哪儿
Tasha: Sister Qu, where's that bowl?
Alice:啊你给他拿上去
Alice: Ah, take it to him.
Tasha: 打蛋盆
Tasha: The egg-beating bowl.
Alice:顺便骂他一下
Alice: And scold him while you're at it.
其他人：哈哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahahahaha
Tasha: 哦在这儿呢擦干的是吗
Tasha: Oh, here it is. Wiped clean, right?
Alice:说呢顾头不顾定
Alice: See, only cares about the head, not the tail.
其他人：外面没擦里面擦
Others: Wiped the outside, not the inside.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Okay.
Alice:这个小不小
Alice: Is this small enough?
Shure: 告诉AI不能这样子
Shure: Tell the AI it can't be like this.
Tasha: 这个我我我想要更小一点
Tasha: I want it even smaller.
Tasha: 就是这这个边的哦嗯
Tasha: Just this edge, oh, um.
Alice:就是这个边的
Alice: Just this edge.
Alice:哦满足
Alice: Oh, satisfied.
Shure: 太饿了
Shure: I'm so hungry.
Shure: 真的很无语
Shure: Really speechless.
Shure: 赶紧滚哈
Shure: Hurry up and get lost, ha.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure: 走上去
Shure: Go upstairs.
Shure: 上去
Shure: Go up.
Shure: 他不没电了吗
Shure: Isn't it out of power?
Katrina: 哈喽哈喽
Katrina: Hello, hello.
Shure: 啊那个钥匙扣啊
Shure: Ah, that keychain.
Katrina: 上楼吧速速开始
Katrina: Let's go upstairs, start quickly.
Shure: 可以可以
Shure: Okay, okay.
Katrina: 迟到43分钟哈哈哈
Katrina: Late by 43 minutes, hahaha.
Shure: 现在也可以
Shure: Now it's okay too.
Lucia: 我们我再找个充电宝把
Lucia: Let me find another power bank.
Alice:薇薇你朋友来吗
Alice: Tasha, is your friend coming?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mm.
Lucia: 我的那个啥哎
Lucia: My, that thing, hey.
Lucia: 我刚刚那个充电宝的线上哪去了
Lucia: Where did the power bank cable go?
Lucia: 这是我的线吗
Lucia: Is this my line?
Lucia: 哦这是我的线
Lucia: Oh, this is my line.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 这个吧OK
Lucia: This one, okay.
Lucia: 我们可以先上楼坐一会
Lucia: Can we go upstairs and sit for a while?
Tasha: 就这样吧
Tasha: Just like this.
Tasha: 起的那个锅铲
Tasha: The spatula you picked up.
Tasha: 什么那个硅胶铲在哪里
Tasha: Where is the silicone spatula?
Tasha: 好像是干的
Tasha: It seems to be dry.
其他人： 是干的
Others: It's dry.
Tasha: 然后再拿个表花带在冰箱 上
Tasha: 把草莓洗一下
Tasha: Wash the strawberries.
Tasha: 和蓝莓
Tasha: And blueberries.
其他人：好
Others: Okay.
Tasha: 放着就行啊
Tasha: Just leave them there.
Tasha: 草莓和草莓
Tasha: Strawberries and strawberries.
Tasha: 各洗一盒吧
Tasha: Wash a box of each.
Tasha: 啊不够还有一盒嘞
Tasha: Ah, not enough, there's another box.
Jake:就是它得
Jake: It has to...
Jake:它在一直在闪它才是充电
Jake: It has to keep flashing to charge.
Jake:所以要比较小心
Jake: So be careful.
Jake:就不像这么明显
Jake: It's not that obvious.
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Katrina: 上吧
Katrina: Let's go.
Katrina: 开始了得
Katrina: It's starting.
其他人：会要我的命
Others: It will be the death of me.
Jake:好那我们这边就算可以开始还需要
Jake: Okay, so we can start here, but we still need...
Alice:挤奶油
Alice: To squeeze the cream.
Jake:挤奶油要不就
Jake: To squeeze the cream, or...
Jake:挤奶油大概要多久
Jake: How long does it take to squeeze the cream?
Jake:还是说可以把它冻起来
Jake: Or can we freeze it?
Alice:什么冻起来
Alice: Freeze what?
Jake:就放冰箱冻起来给他们一起挤之类的
Jake: Just put it in the fridge, freeze it, and squeeze it together later.
Jake:我们得
Jake: We have to...
Jake:那我们如果在这开始
Jake: If we start here...
Jake:我们可能也不能不能开始
Jake: We might not be able to start.
Alice:薇薇你还好吗
Alice: Tasha, are you okay?
Alice:感觉好累
Alice: You look so tired.
Alice:休息好了吗
Alice: Did you rest well?
Tasha: 没有我一会儿还有别的事儿
Tasha: No, I have other things to do later.
Lucia: 有什么可以帮忙的吗
Lucia: Is there anything I can help with?
Alice:的朋友到了吗
Alice: Have your friends arrived?
Lucia: 到了到了
Lucia: Yes, they're here.
Alice:现在人齐了吗
Alice: Is everyone here now?
Lucia: 齐了吧应该
Lucia: I think so.
Lucia: 如果大家还有朋友没到
Lucia: If anyone's friends haven't arrived yet...
Jake:剪刀
Jake: Scissors.
Jake:可能要帮师傅翻一下
Jake: Might need to help the master flip it.
Lucia: 啊好的
Lucia: Ah, got it.
Lucia: 我冲一下手翻啊马上
Lucia: I'll wash my hands and flip it right away.
Alice:小吗这个口
Alice: Is this opening too small?
Tasha: 不小挤吧
Tasha: Not small, squeeze it.
Alice:我挤得挺丑的
Alice: I squeezed it pretty badly.
Alice:我可以挤平面吗
Alice: Can I squeeze it flat?
Tasha: 挤吧
Tasha: Go ahead.
Tasha: 要不你把蛋糕这个切 一下行吗
Tasha: Or can you cut this cake?
Alice:切一下切成两半的吗
Alice: Cut it in half?
Tasha: 有的要切对半
Tasha: Some need to be halved.
Alice:都切两半
Alice: Cut all in half?
Tasha: 有一半切对半就行
Tasha: Just half of them.
Alice:都在这呢
Alice: They're all here.
Alice:我们的案板呢
Alice: Where's our cutting board?
Alice:对干净的吗
Alice: Right, is it clean?
其他人：感觉侈有 根头发
Others: Feels like there's a hair on it.
Lucia: 应该或许大概也许是涮一
Lucia: Maybe, possibly, probably needs a rinse.
Alice:甩一下
Alice: Shake it off.
Lucia: 下吧我去把那个啥翻一下啊
Lucia: I'll go flip that thing now.
Lucia: 翻好了OK
Lucia: Done flipping, okay.
Tasha: 都把这个壳去掉啊
Tasha: Remove all the shells from this.
Lucia: 唐
Lucia: 抓不住
Lucia: Can't hold it.
Jake:这怎么连了一片下去
Jake: How did it end up in one piece?
Lucia: 不行我完全抓不住
Lucia: No, I can't hold it at all.
Lucia: 拆半天光拆下来一个
Lucia: Took so long and only got one off.
Lucia: 这个呢也不好吃
Lucia: This one isn't tasty either.
Jake:哦哦哦
Jake: Oh oh oh.
Lucia: 这个一会还用吗
Lucia: Will we need this later?
Lucia: 要不要再洗一下了
Lucia: Should I wash it again?
Tasha: 不用了都
Tasha: No need.
Jake:好我们挤完就
Jake: Alright, we'll finish squeezing then...
Alice:拿上去
Alice: Take it up.
Jake:拿到
Jake: Got it.
Jake:拿到哪去啊这个
Jake: Where should we take it?
Lucia: 这个那个
Lucia: This one or that one?
Lucia: 哪个上面的那个吗
Lucia: The one on the top?
Jake:这个我们是在这摆拍完是吧
Jake: Are we just staging this here?
Lucia: 那边没有电子产品吗
Lucia: No electronic devices over there?
Lucia: 香啊这葡萄
Lucia: These grapes smell great.
Jake:哎你们你们要不暖场
Jake: Hey, you guys either warm up the place...
Jake:要不下来干活
Jake: ...or get to work.
Jake:就你不能坐着知道不
Jake: You can't just sit around, you know?
Jake:所谓剧组成员
Jake: We're a crew after all.
Alice:咋了
Alice: What's up?
其他人：怎么干活
Others: How do we work?
Jake:把把这个把收拾收拾
Jake: Clean this up.
Lucia: 暖不了一点
Lucia: Can't warm it up a bit.
Alice:收拾
Alice: Clean up.
Jake:然后把这收掉
Jake: And then clear this out.
Alice:这个晚上还要装他吗
Alice: Do we still need to set this up tonight?
Jake:信马上就要整满
Jake: It'll be filled soon.
Tasha: 不就只有这个小房子不要了
Tasha: Isn't it just this small house that we don't need anymore?
Jake:刘帅呢董叉呢
Jake: Where's Choiszt and Jack?
Jake:在干嘛
Jake: What are they doing?
Jake:他们他们他们他们在暖吗
Jake: Are they warming up?
其他人：MAYBE
Others: MAYBE.
Lucia: 应该差不多
Lucia: Should be almost done.
其他人：这个要吗
Others: Do we need this?
Alice:不要
Alice: No.
其他人：都不要了
Others: No, we don't.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
其他人：就这吧
Others: Just this one.
Alice:呃
Alice: Uh...
Lucia: 怒偷一本武林秘籍
Lucia: Steal a martial arts manual.
Jake:哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Jake:放在这边擦干的是吧
Jake: Put it here to dry, right?
Lucia: 小心那个地方刚擦干
Lucia: Be careful, that spot just dried.
Lucia: 要不还是换个地方放
Lucia: Maybe put it somewhere else.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 因为这是纸容易受潮
Lucia: Because it's paper, it can get damp easily.
Alice:是不是饮料洒了
Alice: Did a drink spill?
Alice:怎么闻见一股果汁味呢
Alice: Why do I smell juice?
Lucia: 哈是刚才有一瓶那个
Lucia: Haha, there was a bottle of...
其他人：葡萄汁
Others: Grape juice.
Lucia: 这个这是谁的
Lucia: Whose is this?
Alice:你咋不在上面呢
Alice: Why weren't you up there?
其他人：我在上卫生间
Others: I was in the restroom.
Alice:卫生间那上面也有卫生间啊
Alice: There's a restroom up there too.
Lucia: 上面也有
Lucia: There's one up there too.
Lucia: 呃没事你都下来了就去吧哈哈哈
Lucia: It's fine, since you're already down here, just go. Haha.
其他人：马上来了
Others: Coming right away.
Jake:还有啥这个要洗掉对吧
Jake: What else needs to be washed off, right?
Jake:这些都不要哎
Jake: We don't need these, right?
Alice:yes
Alice: Yes.
Jake:为什么现在有手套呢
Jake: Why do we have gloves now?
Alice:因为刚来的
Alice: Because they just arrived.
Jake:这
Jake: These...
Jake:些该放哪儿
Jake: Where should these go?
Tasha: 这八个都放到空上托盘啊都放到那个小架子上
Tasha: These eight go on the empty tray, all on the small shelf.
Alice:那个架子脏脏着
Alice: That shelf is dirty.
Jake:那这这这8个是吧
Jake: So these eight, right?
Tasha: 那就放托盘
Tasha: Then put them on the tray.
Jake:夹子脏脏的就垫一下吧
Jake: If the shelf is dirty, just line it with paper.
Jake:这个这个纸
Jake: This, this paper...
Alice:纸在这儿
Alice: The paper is here.
Katrina: 哇还有麦旋风吗
Katrina: Wow, is there still McFlurry?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Alice:麦旋风
Alice: McFlurry.
Jake:昨晚的麦旋风
Jake: Last night's McFlurry.
Tasha: 干嘛
Tasha: Why?
Jake:垫垫上
Jake: To line the tray.
Tasha: 剪很窄的就行了
Tasha: Just cut a narrow piece.
Tasha: 剪跟它
Tasha: Cut it along with...
Alice:还有3分钟啥
Alice: There's still 3 minutes left.
Katrina: 4点开始
Katrina: Starts at 4.
Tasha: 刀剪一下
Tasha: Cut it with the knife.
Alice:在那在那
Alice: Over there, over there.
Lucia: 因为那个剪刀
Lucia: Because those scissors...
Lucia: 刚才好像不是用来剪快递的嘛
Lucia: Weren't they used to cut the package just now?
Alice:啊我已经用来接他
Alice: Ah, I already used them.
Lucia: 所以啊也没事
Lucia: So, it's fine.
Alice:无所谓了
Alice: Doesn't matter.
Jake:没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake:没没听见没听见
Jake: Didn't hear it, didn't hear it.
Lucia: 嗯确实
Lucia: Yeah, indeed.
Lucia: 拜拜
Lucia: Bye-bye.
Jake:我们这个摆在上面吗
Jake: Should we put this on top?
Jake:还是摆在下面
Jake: Or put it on the bottom?
Tasha: 这个还没洗呢
Tasha: This isn't washed yet.
Alice:剪了吧剪了吧
Alice: Cut it, cut it.
Jake:剪一下剪一下
Jake: Cut it, cut it.
Alice:那底下呢底下呢
Alice: What about the bottom, the bottom?
Jake:耶好
Jake: Yay, good.
Jake:行
Jake: Okay.
Jake:来水
Jake: Bring the water.
Jake:那就上去喷喷水
Jake: Just go spray some water.
Jake:这个就往上面摆喽
Jake: We'll just put this on top.
Lucia: 请大家先喝点矿泉水
Lucia: Everyone, please have some mineral water first.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Alice:那个太长了
Alice: That one is too long.
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay.
Alice:就光底下那个底就行了
Alice: Just the bottom part is fine.
Lucia: 好看啊
Lucia: It looks nice.
Lucia: 哦底下是不是还需要一条
Lucia: Oh, does the bottom need one more?
Jake:一会我们端上去吗
Jake: Are we bringing it up later?
Alice:在上面还是在下边
Alice: On top or on the bottom?
Jake:端上去吧下面
Jake: Bring it up, the bottom.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Alice:没没啥就等着
Alice: Nothing, just waiting.
Katrina: 这两个都是新的吧
Katrina: Are these both new?
其他人：还要烤吗
Others: Do we still need to bake it?
Alice:哪个
Alice: Which one?
Alice:对有一个杨老板的
Alice: Yeah, one is Jake's.
Katrina: 两个都是他的吗
Katrina: Are both of them his?
Alice:有一个是
Alice: One is.
Alice:另外一个不知道
Alice: The other one, not sure.
Katrina: 他有预定哪一个吗
Katrina: Did he reserve either?
Katrina: 应该都是新的吧
Katrina: They should both be new, right?
Alice:没有嗯
Alice: No, hmm.
Alice:因为昨天这是画的
Alice: Because this was painted yesterday.
Katrina: 我拿我朋友吃
Katrina: I'll take it for my friend to eat.
Tasha: 这个怎么没拿上去哦
Tasha: Why didn't this get taken up?
Tasha: 还有四个呢
Tasha: There are still four more.
Alice:这儿呢这儿这儿这儿
Alice: Here, here, here, here.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
其他人：这个也可以放呈
Others: This one can also be displayed.
其他人：好
Others: Okay.